China's very happy that I'm permanently
opening the straight of Hormuz.
>> When you threaten a ship that's flagged
by China, this is effectively an act of
war on China. China's got 600 nuclear
weapons here.
>> Is there a concern that President Xi
starts looking like the real adult in
the room?
>> I can see a situation in which the
Europeans see China as a diplomatic
savior. The
>> question is, how long can President
Trump keep this up? What is this?
>> Pope Leo has a plus 34 popularity rating
in the United States. Trump has a -12.
It's eer to take a fight like that.
>> We sent them a lot of guns. We sent them
through the Kurds. And the president
says he thinks the Kurds kept them.
>> Did you steal them?
>> A lot of people stolen. Can't speak for
the other side.
>> Keep on protesting. The US president
told the Iranian people in January. Help
is on its way. Well, many Iranians in
the diaspora held pictures and banners
of Trump as they protested in London,
Washington DC, and even LA. Others
appeared frequently in the media,
including on the show, to make the case
for war. The people in Iran are
suffering, they said. The time to act is
now. After more than six weeks of war,
and with the president scrambling for an
escape route, it's fair to ask whether
acting now helped the Iranian people at
all. The faces and some of the names
have changed, but the regime has not. A
lot of its military power has been
destroyed, but none of the power it used
to beat down its own people. It's safe
to assume that many of the Iranians who
chant him for Resa Palavi are now dead,
either the hands of security services or
the bombing campaign. Netanyahu and the
Israelis sold Trump on a revolution,
even as many of us kept asking how that
was even possible without armed
resistance. Last week, Trump told Fox
News that the US did try to arm
protesters by sending weapons via the
Kurds, who, according to the president,
stole them. And they will respond to
that claim later on this show. We'll
begin with a simple question. Who
exactly has been helped by this war?
Well, joining me now is Robert Pap,
international affairs scholar and author
of Escalation Trap on Substack. Welcome
back to Uncensored. Uh Robert, um last
time you were on, I asked you who who
was winning this war. You said the US
could be facing strategic defeat because
of the new significance of the straight
of Hormuse. What is your view as you sit
here today?
>> Um, it's gotten worse. So, what you are
seeing and thank you by the way for
bringing me back. What you are seeing is
we are not on a path of peace. We're
also not on a path of victory. We're on
a path of escalation. And uh what you
were going to see unfold now, not likely
over just the next few days, but now
probably over the coming weeks and
months is a much longer war. So remember
this started was supposed to be just a
fewday air campaign backup air plan for
if it had to go longer four weeks. Well,
we're way blown past four weeks. And
what are we doing? We're escalating.
We're actually moving more forces into
the region this morning. and Iran is now
counter uh counter threatening just this
morning. So what you are seeing with
this blockade is an escalation path and
it is now crossing three thresholds.
Number one, it's widening the war within
the region. So of course it's targeting
Iran, but Iran is saying uh if this goes
forward, we're going to knock out or try
to knock out the Red Sea choke point.
Well, they've got some credibility there
with the Houthis. Number two, um uh the
blockade, the US blockade is now going
to be um crossing thresholds with China.
And we need to understand that when you
um threaten a ship that's flagged by
China or going to China, this is
effectively an act of war on China.
China's got 600 nuclear weapons here.
So, this is a not a small thing that is
occurring here. And then number three,
as I was indicating before, this is now
uh moving to a much longer war scenario
than is even currently being discussed.
And what that means is lock in of those
economic effects of the blockade of uh
the 20% oil, 30% fertilizer, etc., etc.,
possibly now the Red Sea for the world
economy. So you're locking in that not
just for a day but for probably weeks
and months for sure. Something I don't
know why the markets don't want to price
this in but you know markets have been
wrong before but this is what's actually
the reality of what's occurring. And how
significant is the fact that it appears
that uh Lebanon was initially supposed
to have been included in the ceasefire
agreement but then Israel said
absolutely not and has carried on uh
bombarding Lebanon as they go after
Hezbollah. How significant has that been
as part of all this?
>> Uh yeah. So what Israel has done uh in
my view is played the role of spoiler
all the way through. So every time you
see this going back to last May for
example uh before we bombed for fore
before the 12 day war every time we get
close to something that looks like a
workable negotiation. I mean not not
even like a deal but just workable. Um
you see Israel acting in ways that are
militarily uh a spoiler uh threatening
the deal. Uh, in May, uh, Israel started
the 12-day war by literally bombing to
death the negotiators we were supposed
to meet with, and they knew the time and
place of where they would be because of
the negotiation. So, so we gave them
essentially the targeting information.
And now that's just one of many
instances that have happened since. So,
uh, Israel is clearly spoiling the, uh,
the negotiation track. Uh, and it's now
becoming even, I think, beyond Israel
spoiling. I mean, if you're in Iran's uh
shoes, the idea you're really going to
rely on the negotiation track, this is
just uh I I think uh we we're long past
that moment.
>> And in relation to China, they declared
on Monday that the US blockade of
Iranian oil leaving the straight of
Hormuse was dangerous and irresponsible.
Well, Trump has posted on Truth Social,
China's very happy that I'm permanently
opening the straight of Hormuse. I'm
doing it for them also and the world.
This situation will never happen again.
They've agreed not to send weapons to
Iran. President Xi will give me a big
fat hug when I get there in a few weeks.
We're working together smartly and very
well. Doesn't that beat fighting, but
remember, we are very good at fighting
if we have to. Far better than everybody
else, President Trump. Um, you know,
he's due to go and see President Xi.
That's been delayed obviously by this
war. uh you know there are people out
there that think that this is a much
bigger picture play by Trump and the
Americans which is not about their own
oil because obviously America's pretty
well self-sufficient when it comes to
energy but about controlling the global
supply because obviously China relies so
much on on oil from places like Iran
that actually um that's always been the
big picture here as we saw with
Venezuela as why Trump wants uh
Greenland and uh why he wants to you
know have some control of a straight of
hormones whatever it may be that there's
a sort of big a bigger thing going on
here which is about the control of
global energy do you buy into that
>> well last June when we were bombing for
I was spending two weeks in China
visiting its advanced industries the
Xiaomé that's electric vehicle BYD
Alibaba and having dinners with all of
these executives and also the power some
of the power players here in China as uh
and what they were quite clear was they
may lose a few percentage points of GDP
if the United States gets sucked into a
quagmire in the Middle East, but they
gain enormous power here relative to the
United States. So, they were absolutely
not wanting to get in their arrivals way
of sticking their nose into this deeper
and deeper. and the idea that we've got
this leverage over them. Well, 80% of
their um needs don't come from oil
energy needs don't come from oil at all.
And in fact, they're moving even more
aggressively into solar power, not
because they're liberals, but because
this is their growth plan for the
future. So, I saw all that up close and
personal for two solid weeks, 18 hours a
day at the shop floor, all the plans.
And so, this this is just uh not real. I
mean, we're strengthening, we're we're
hastening the day when China will flip
and become number one. We're not
reducing that. We're not making that
slower. Pierce, what's happening is um
all of these so-called talking points
here. Uh for example, you say, "Well,
President Trump just posted, she will be
thrilled with this." Fine. Then all the
White House has to do is get that post
endorsed by the uh Chinese Foreign
Ministry today. We don't need to wait
weeks and weeks for a meeting. All we
know that this is an inter you're you're
I'm in Chicago. You're in London. We can
do this in the next 30 minutes at at the
longest. That's all that would take
there. Otherwise, this is just more hot
work, hot breath coming out of uh
President Trump and he's had a lot of
that that just simply doesn't matter.
>> Robert P, great to have you back. Thank
you very much.
>> Thank you. So the big question is, is
China the real and potentially the only
big winner? Joining me to debate this is
Jang Sha Twin, game theorist, better
known as Professor Jang, and Gordon
Chang, author of Plan Red, China's
Project to Destroy America. Well,
welcome to both of you. Um, well,
welcome back to Uncensored, uh, Jang
Shaitin. Um,
what is your view? I mean there is a
view that's mounting that China by not
being directly involved has been the
biggest beneficiary. Do you share that?
I
>> I actually don't share that view peers.
Um I think that China could suffer many
consequences if this war continues for
too long. So China China has has already
invested $200 billion into the Middle
East. All this infrastructure investment
could be destroyed. So uh Iran is a very
important part of China's belt and road
initiative and the Israelis and
Americans are targeting uh railways
railways built by um built with Chinese
financing. China receives 50 to 60% of
its energy needs from the Middle East
for the HMU and so uh right now China is
using it strategic reserves uh to fuel
its economy but if this work continues
for too long then the Chinese economy
may suffer.
So that's very interesting uh because
you know I've been reading a lot of
reports increasingly saying no no no
China that they're going to benefit and
yet you come back all the time in my
head anyway to the fact that China is
you know pretty reliant on the straight
of Hormuse in particular being open.
It's the it's the biggest beneficiary of
that straight being open. And so even
though some of their oil has been
getting through, it's not been all all
of it, has it?
>> Right. So remember that this weekend
there were the peace talks in Islamabad.
And these peace talks would not have
happened without China's um without
China pressuring the Iranians to seek a
ceasefire as soon as possible. Iranians
are not interested in a ceasefire
because they see themselves as winning
this war and they have absolutely and
they believe the Americans don't have
any credibility. Um they've had peace
talks before and it's gone nowhere. In
fact, the Israelis and Americans have
used a pretext of peace talks to attack
the Iranians. So I think without um
Chinese diplomatic efforts, these peace
talks would not have uh occurred in
Islamabad. And then you have to ask
yourself why are the Chinese so invested
in peace in the Middle East? And the
reason why is they have too much
invested in energy from the Middle East.
>> Okay, Gordon Chang. Um, you know, I I
have been really struggling. I'll be
honest with you. I've known Donald Trump
20 years. The reasons for this war seem
to have changed on an hourly basis for
the last six weeks. He seems to be
deliberately antagonizing everyone he
can think of. I mean, today he's been
antagonizing every Christian. um he's
been uh antagonizing obviously everyone
in NATO, everyone in Europe. Um he
doesn't seem to care. And yet most of
the concerns from the people that he's
going after are shared by all of them,
which is this war was illconceived, has
been poorly executed, has no apparent
endgame, and is being driven
predominantly by the interests of
Benjamin Netanyahu and his Israeli
government. What is your view?
I think that the war certainly was
necessary and I don't I agree with you.
I don't think President Trump has made
the case. So for instance, when he
talked to the American people about 10
days ago, he only used conclusory
statements and I don't think that they
were that convincing. So for instance,
he said, "Well, you know, the Iranians
will soon have a a missile that'll hit
the United States." Well, they very well
could have that missile right now,
peers, because we know that since 2016,
the US Treasury has been sanctioning
North Korea and Iran because North Korea
has transferred all the components for a
Wasang 15. A Wasang 15 has a range of
8,100 miles and if fired from Iranian
territory can hit any part of the United
States. We know that Iran has all the
pieces. The only thing we don't know is
whether Iran has been able to put those
pieces together. And uh President Trump
did not make the case on Iran's
possession of highlyenriched uranium,
which he could have done. He just said,
"Well, they have they want a nuclear
weapon." But it was a much more
convincing case he could have made. And
I think that eventually he will make
that. I think eventually the American
people will understand that and I think
that they will support the war. But of
course the question is as you point out
whether Trump will make that case to um
publics American and the world.
>> Well I don't see how he can successfully
sell us the premise that this was always
about preventing them building a nuclear
weapon when the enriched uranium which
is quite a long way advanced on that
path remains massively underground
heavily protected and the Americans and
Israelis haven't got a single tiny dot
of it. So, as long as it remains there,
and obviously getting it out of the
ground would be incredibly hazardous,
particularly if they deploy ground
troops, I don't know how you can say
that you've you've destroyed their
chances of making a nuclear weapon. He
said all that after the 12-day war last
summer, and then within nine months, we
were back again on the same pretext. I
none of this makes sense to me.
>> Well, if you're talking about President
Trump's statements, I I certainly agree
with you. But there's certain things
that we need to point out and one of
them is that we don't know where that
460 kgs of 60% enriched uranium is,
>> right?
>> And if it's not buried underground and
if the Iranians have access to it, then
you know they could very well turn that
into um you know 90% enriched uranium.
And by the way, we know that it's 60%
only because they told us. So it could
very well be 90%. So yes, um there is a
imminent threat or a near imminent
threat and I think President Trump did
not make that case. But if you look at
the facts, I do believe that they bear
out the uh clear and present danger
assessment that the American government
has in fact made.
>> And in terms of China itself, you got
into a little bit of a spat with Donald
Trump on air actually at Fox the other
day. Let's take a look.
I have a very good relationship with
President Xi of China. We work together
very well. They're paying us substantial
money as you know. We've never got money
before. You know, I listen to this
Gordon Chang. He has no idea what he's
talking about. We have been very tough
on China. Tough but fair. And uh you
know, it's an amazing place, but I have
a very good relationship with China. And
they've been doing my you know, I put
tremendous tariffs. I put a 100% tariff
on all Chinese cars coming in and that's
destroying Europe.
>> So Gordon, you have no idea what you
what you're talking about. I think we
can add you to the list of a thousand
people he has trashed in the last six
weeks. So don't take it personally. But
but in relation to that, you know,
earlier we just heard Professor Chang
saying that China has not benefited from
this war. Do you agree with that? And do
you think that uh Trump has been too
soft on China?
Yeah, first of all, um I don't think
this war is in China's interest, and I
agree with Professor John for a lot of
reasons. You know, we've seen the spike
in oil, but more important, the spike in
diesel prices in China. Now, the
National Development and Reform
Commission has been trying to moderate
those. Yes, China does have the world's
largest strategic petroleum reserve, but
at most hits 140, 150 days of import
cover. The real problem for China though
is that China is now extraordinarily
trade dependent and that's because
Cinping has turned his back on
consumption as the basis of the Chinese
economy which means that China's only
hope for growth is trade exports but in
a deglobalizing world and it's
deglobalizing because of conflict around
the world some of which China is
responsible for by the way um we're
seeing um countries pull back and that's
not good for a trade dependent country.
So in a delobalizing world, China could
very well be the biggest victim of the
trends.
>> Professor Jang, Donald Trump's deadline
for imposing a blockade of the straight
of Hormoose is sort of upon us. No one's
quite sure how he's going to implement
this. What do you think about this idea
of a kind of revenge blockade driven by
the United States?
>> Right. So there's a lot there's a lot of
concern that a naval blockade is not
feasible because if you try to blockade
this sort of moves then you're within
range of Iranian drones as well as
ballistic missiles. But if you um step
back and you look think about the larger
strategy at work here, I think that
Gordon is right in that um China is very
much an export dependent economy and
it's very reliant on free access to
maritime choke points such as the
straight of Humus and the of Malaa. So
if Iran can uh impose tolls in the
street of uh Hmuds, there's actually no
reason why the American military cannot
impose ter uh terrorists and tolls on
the street of Malaa and so that would u
raise tremendous costs for for China.
And so maybe the overall strategy is not
really directed at Iran but really at
strangling the Chinese economy. And you
can you can do that by actually um
restraining China's access in certain
key maritime choke points. But you know,
China could of course uh as it did in
the tariff war, it could hit back very
strongly if it chose to. I mean, I've
been I've stood in Shanghai port, which
I think is the biggest port in the
world, uh and watched everything going
out of there to uh the West
predominantly uh if China was to flex
its muscles in restricting access of its
goods to the world, it might suffer, of
course, itself short-term economic harm,
but it would cause a lot of damage to
the global economy elsewhere. So they
they it's not like they're powerless,
right?
>> Well, um as Gordon pointed out, China is
an export dependent economy. So China
benefits more from trading with the
world and the world benefits from
trading with China. So it makes no sense
for China to impose an embargo on the
world. It can't really do that. Um the
major question is does China have a
bluewater navy to challenge uh American
hegemony over the seas? And the answer
is it doesn't. And the problem is that
if China were to start challenging uh
America in the seas, especially um the
sh of Malaka, then that would activate
the the Japanese military. And Japan has
actually the um best blue water navy in
East Asia.
>> Okay. Gordon Chang, you know, roughly
90% of Iran's crude oil exports go to
China. Um that oil revenue supplies
around a quarter of Iran's budget. a
huge portion of which is then spent on
its military. Without China, the regime
wouldn't be able to pay its security
forces, couldn't subsidize basic goods,
and would soon face internal collapse.
That is the theory that is, I think,
guiding some of President Trump's uh
decision-m over a potential blockade and
so on because Iran has become in itself
utterly dependent on China. Do you
understand the rationale for the
blockade based on that?
>> Yes. And by the way, on Saturday, two
Arley Burks, American destroyers,
transited the straight of Hormuz twice
and they did so without arrangement with
Iran. So I think that if you parked a
couple Arley Burks in just outside the
straight, um you could close it. And
that's what President Trump has talked
about. He said that look, we're going to
seize any ship that has paid Iran's
tolls. Um this uh cuts off uh all of its
oil revenue. Um so really what we have
is an a strategy to starve the regime.
Whether it will bring down the regime, I
don't know. This regime is extremely
resilient. But after a while when you
have no money at all um coming in, then
really you don't have a war effort on
the part of the Iranians. So I think
that eventually this will work. And the
question is how long can President Trump
keep this up? I think that he can keep
it up a lot longer than most people
believe. Um, so there is the makings of
a strategy. Um, and I think that it
probably will work. Professor Jang, I
mean, there's a lot of chatter about
what China's view of all this has been,
and you've articulated it very well, I
think, why they it's actually more of a
concern than a benefit. Um it's
obviously the war has exposed the
fragility of the global economy when it
comes to who controls the straight of
Hormuz. That is obvious and Iran now
knows that and of course other actors
around the world now know that if you
control a waterway through which a lot
of the world's goods or energy flow then
you can cause paralysis around the
world. So that won't have gone unnoticed
I'm sure to people like Vladimir Putin.
Um but but you have also conversely had
a revelation here that you can paralyze
to a degree
uh China in terms of its energy flow
coming out of places like Iran. Uh and
that may be what Donald Trump has
belatedly picked up on. Some people
think that this was always his
intention. I don't think it was. Uh but
I think he's now realized actually this
kind of uh use of the waterways as an
economic battering ram could work both
ways. Hence the blockade.
Yeah, you're absolutely right. Um Donald
Trump is first and foremost concerned
with using American military power to
benefit America first. And right now
America has about $39 trillion in debt.
And um we've seen these past few years
that many nations in Europe and East
Asia are shifting away from US
treasuries and purchasing more gold. If
the trend continues, then America could
face a severe debt crisis. And so the
way to elevate um this crisis is by
forcing Europe and East Asia to depend
more on North American resources, right?
So LNG from America. And you can do that
by sabotaging the economies of the GCC
by imposing a naval blockade uh in the
Middle East. Um and so maybe there's a
grand plan here.
>> Gordon Chang, uh what does this all mean
for Taiwan? Um you know, America gets
bogged down in Iran, its military
credibility is damaged.
Have the has the decision to do this
given China if it wishes a green light
to go and take Taiwan? In other words,
has it removed the West's high moral
ground and ability to complain if they
now go and do the same thing to Taiwan
which uh Trump has done in Iran. or it
it's obviously not exactly the same
thing, but in terms of attacking,
>> it's very different because um Iran was
clearly violating their obligations
under the nuclear non-prololiferation
treaty. Um they attacked Israel savagely
on October 7th. Um Iran's president in
December said that there was a state of
war between the United States and Iran.
So, you know, it's very different. The
thing about Taiwan, and yes, the US has
drawn down its stocks. They used them in
Iran. Um and this does create a
vulnerability but Cinping has decimated
the top of the Chinese military with his
continual purges and from what we can
tell there have been um people uh who
have been Cinping's loyalists who have
been purged by Cining's adversary. So
there is turmoil at the top of the
Chinese military. Now to invade Taiwan
or at least the main island of Taiwan,
you have to have a combined airland sea
operation, which means you need
coordination at the top of the Chinese
military and just one detail. The
Communist Party Central Military
Commission, which controls the military,
normally had seven members on it a
couple months ago. Now it has only two,
Cining and a political commasar. There
are no operational officers left on the
central military commission which means
that an invasion of Taiwan at least for
this moment is off the table.
>> Do you agree with that professor Jang?
>> I think um another cons consideration um
are the Japanese. Um the Japanese prime
minister has stated that um Taiwan is
part of Japan's national strategic
interest and if China were to take over
Taiwan then China can impose a naval
blockade um on Japan. it could it could
basically shut off the sh Malika to
Japanese um trade and so this would
would present an existential crisis to
Japan. So um if there is any intention
on part of China to take over Taiwan
then Japanese would uh intervene. So I
do not believe that in the ne next 5 to
10 years there's any consideration of an
invasion of Taiwan. But it's interesting
that the way you described what China
could potentially do because of course
if you're China and you're looking at
what's happened with the straight of
moose that idea that you just proposed
as possibly in their thinking becomes a
lot more effective right I mean if they
wanted to cause real economic damage to
Japan and others they could just do a
similar thing over there
>> but China is an export or dependent
economy. So if global trade stops then
it hurts itself more than than other
people.
>> Simple as that.
>> And the other thing peers is that yes,
Japan, South Korea, Taiwan get an
enormous percentage, you know, 90% of
their energy through the straight of
Hormuz. Right now, we have these very
large crude carriers in the Gulf of
Mexico or Gulf of America because
they're picking up American energy from
Texas and Louisiana. So, that energy
trade will redirect. Of course, it will
cause severe disruptions in East Asia
for a little while, but America has the
energy to sell.
>> Professor Jang, is there a concern, do
you think? I don't know who the concern
would predominantly be with, but Donald
Trump has been behaving very erratically
on the global stage and been
deliberately
uh attacking a lot of his allies from
the UK to France to Spain to Germany and
others NATO.
Is there a concern that President Xi
starts looking like the real adult in
the room and that the United States
loses that role in perception globally?
The Chinese are first and foremost
pramatic. And the Chinese believe in
mutual trade. And so I can see a
situation which the Europeans, the
Russians, the Iranians see China as
possibly a diplomatic savior in the
situation. Um certainly the Chinese were
instrumental in organizing these uh
weekend talks in in Islamabad. So these
talks were not um effective and there
were no results. But we can assume that
these talks will will become a regular
thing even as even as this war
progresses.
>> Gordon Chang, what do you think? I mean,
you know, President Xi's been pretty
quiet, not saying too much, letting this
all play out. Donald Trump's been the
complete opposite, rampaging around,
looking increasingly like someone who's
not quite sure how to get out of this
mess. Um, but if he blames enough
people, eventually somebody might accept
the blame. Um, you know, is President Xi
winning the kind of diplomatic war here
if nothing else?
>> I think he's certainly winning the
propaganda war because he does look
stable. There's no question about that
and that's backed up by all sorts of
anecdotal evidence and surveys. But
peers, um, something had to be done
about NATO. Um, and you know, as Mark
Route, the NATO secretary general said,
um, Trump has been great for NATO
because he's gotten countries, except
for Canada, to agree to that 5% GDP
spending, um, limit, um, or or floor. So
really, these are things that had to be
done. Now, yes, you're right. Trump
should not have threatened war against
Denmark over Greenland. Um, shouldn't
have been making those threats against
Canada. Um, and those are not helpful.
But a lot of what Trump has been saying
and doing was really important because
previous presidents and previous
American presidents have just kicked the
can down the road and let NATO erode.
They let Iran develop nuclear weapons.
They let this and they let that. But
Trump, I think, gets credit for doing
things which are politically unpopular,
but I believe are necessary for the
national security of the United States,
but also for the safety and security of
the international system as a whole.
It's not just America first. This is
America actually guaranteeing uh or
creating the conditions for enduring
peace in the coming decades.
>> I mean that's assuming any of this
works. You know, I would say the problem
the problem with that argument is I can
see why this is all in Netanyahu and
Israel's interests because they just
want to do as much damage in Iran as
they can possibly do and they found a
president that will help them do it and
smash it all up. But in terms of the
American national interest here, if
ultimately this gets resolved with Iran
m retaining its enriched uranium with
the regime still in place, albeit with
different members of it at the top, with
the people not rising up in the way that
the Israelis had assured the Americans
would happen if you decapitated the
Ayatollah and the leadership. you know,
if all these things, if that's how this
plays out and the Iranians have learned
that they can strangle the global
economy at any moment uh through the
straight of Hormus if they want to, I
not a terrible terrible outcome for the
United States.
>> That's a possible outcome, but it's not
the only outcome. And we got to remember
that the war effort is supported not
only by Israel, which is a combatant,
but is also supported by Saudi Arabia
and many of the Gulf Cooperation Council
states. So they do not want Iran to
prevail and they've been helping the
United States and they've been backing
us. So it it's not just Israel, it's I
think the region which has come to the
conclusion that um Iran is a danger that
can no longer be uh sloughed off into
the future. So um yeah, you have a
scenario which is perfectly possible but
there are many other ones as well which
are bright much brighter.
>> Yeah I mean professor Jang there's no
doubt that what the Iranians have done
by attacking its neighboring Gulf states
has massively antagonized the UAE, Saudi
Arabia, Qatar and others. They've gone
after them in their most vulnerable
areas really which are hitting the oil
refineries and hitting tourist areas.
there's been a 10% reduction in uh
people uh defecting not defecting but
leaving uh some of these Gulf states
because they don't they fear it's not
safe anymore if that was to to continue
that trend or they stayed away uh
irrevocably you can see the whole
business model of moving from reliance
on oil which is running out to an
economy through the Gulf states based on
tourism sport uh entertainment and so on
it becomes very difficult to sustain
that if you don't have the people. So,
the stakes are pretty high here, aren't
they?
>> It is possible that GCC does not survive
this war. Um, as you point out, the GCC
is heavily dependent on expatriots uh on
international financing um and on global
trade. And this war has shown that the
GCC is really a mirage um created uh
under illusion that they will be
protected by the American Empire. In
fact, we have the petro dollar system
because the GCC had an agreement uh with
America where the GCC would sell its oil
in US dollars and recycle back into the
US economy in exchange for American
milit military protection. So, not only
did America not start this war without
their consent, but when this war
started, uh the Americans abandoned
their military bases and and sought
shelter in hotels and that's why they
were targeted by Iranian uh drones. So,
this was a very bad deal for the GCC and
um I think it's very hard that for them
to survive this war and that's why I
think there's so much anxiety and
pressure to launch a ground invasion
against Iran.
>> When we spoke uh the last time you
appeared on Uncensored, you were
predicting that America would have to
commit ground troops. Let's take a look.
>> Iran is putting on a lot of pressure on
the GCC. And I think at the end of the
day, um, the United States will be
compelled to send ground forces. Once
the United States sends in ground
forces, there's no turning back. It's
all in. Um, the sun cost fallacy uh,
kicks in. It'll be another Vietnam for
the United States because Iran is a
mountain fortress and uh the United
States right now doesn't have the
manpower, the manu manufactured capacity
and the political will to fight a long
war of attrition on the ground in Iran.
>> Now, you previously predicted correctly
that Trump would win the election. You
predicted the war with Iran. You also
said that the United States would lose
that war ultimately and that remains to
be seen. Um but on that specific
prediction about the United States
eventually having to commit troops, was
that predicated on having to get the ur
the enriched uranium or in trying to
affect a regime change?
>> Yeah, I mean I think it's a ladder where
it is impossible to affect regime change
from the air and it's not sustainable in
the long term. We're already seeing um
American um F-15s, F-35s being downed by
the Iranians because first of all, it's
hard to maintain these expensive $100
million planes in a long war. And second
of all, the Iranians have are developing
um creative air defense strategies uh
against the um Americans. So eventually,
if you want to continue this war, you're
gonna have to send send in ground troops
because it's too expensive to maintain
an air war. But the cost on uh human
life from a ground invasion could be
catastrophic. Not just for the people
who get killed, but also for the massive
political fallout that would head Donald
Trump's way. And of course, he has got
the backdrop of the United States
midterm elections in November.
If you go with the attitude that one
American soldier soldier is worth more
than $100 $100 million F-15 or F-35,
you're going to lose this war,
>> right? So what should the attitude be?
>> Um well, first of all, America should
not be in this war. America should have
negotiated a peace treaty with with
Iran. uh America should have lifted all
uh trade sanctions against Iran and um
allowed for civilian Iranian enrichment
and um this would have bought global
prosperity to the world. Iran the
Iranians were perfectly happy to abide
by a nuclear treaty that they signed
under Obama and that and that treaty was
going very very well. So first of all um
this war should not have started. Now
that this war has started um I think
it's imperative that the Americans
recognize that this war is lost. it
cannot be win and refuse to commit
ground troops because once it sets it
commits ground troops then this war
becomes let's call let's see mission
creep be like a another Vietnam so right
now it's a turning point I implore the
Americans do not send in ground troops
once you send in ground troops you're
stuck there for 10 years
>> yeah I think that's almost certainly
true I mean Gordon Chang you know it
paint that paints a pretty rosy picture
of the Iranian regime you know towing
the line on the global stage they've
shown very little evidence they would do
that. And in fact, of course, the whole
point of the war from the Israeli point
of view is that they've been the the
octopus providing the tentacles of
terrorism to the Houthis, to Hezbollah,
to Hamas, to terrorize Israel for
several decades now. And that is why
Israel wanted to neutralize that threat.
And that is why Netanyahu worked so hard
to persuade Donald Trump to bring
America into it. Um, I mean, do you
think that the picture there that
Professor Jang paints of Iran being a
reliable actor perhaps if we' done
things differently, is that is that a
likely scenario?
>> Yeah, I don't share it. So, for
instance, with the joint comprehensive
plan of action, the JCPOA that President
Obama negotiated, we know that the
Iranians violated it. Um and President
Trump um when he pulled out said he
couldn't certify compliance and we know
that the Iranians were stalling and
preventing inspections which were part
of that plan and that was a direct
contravention of its obligations. So no,
I don't think Iran can be trusted. Um
I'd like to think that they could. Um
but at least on on that one and which
that's the most direct precedent that we
have, we have seen that they violated
it. And by the way, they have 60%
enriched uranium which they admitted to.
And so that's clearly a violation as
well. You just go through the list of
this PICE and I just don't think that
Iran could be trusted. It's unfortunate,
but that's the nature of the regime. It
wanted a nuclear weapon, absolutely
determined to get it, and it would lie
and cheat and steal, which it did.
>> What is your prediction, um, Gordon
Chang, for how this plays out?
Well, how it plays out is determined by
one individual, um, President Trump.
And, um, I don't know. You know, you
you're absolutely right when you say
he's unpredictable. Um, now, we know
what he says. Um, I think that he is as
good as his word um, on these issues for
various reasons. He's been consistent
about Iran not getting a nuclear weapon.
Um, he started this war, which he knew
was going to be unpopular. So, he's
obviously determined to see it through.
Um, but you know, as I said, it's it's
it's up to one individual and we're just
going to have to see. I as I said, I
think he's going to be as good as his
word.
>> Finally, Professor Jang, I couldn't uh
let you go without mentioning an
encounter you had with Medi Hassan,
who's a regular on Uncensored, in which
he said you're misleading people because
you're not actually a professor. And
secondly, he called you China's useful
idiot. here is your chance to respond to
these two charges. What would you like
to say?
>> Um, first of all, he's absolutely right.
I am not a professor. I am not a
credential professor. I'm a high school
teacher. Um, we have a pretty popular
YouTube following. And it's the internet
that has called me professor. Um, in
China, it's a sign of respect to call
someone a professor regardless of his
credentials. So, it's entirely up up to
you whether or not to call me um a uh
professor. And the second point that I'm
a useful idiot. Um, look, it is entirely
possible that an algorithm is is popping
me up because I'm saying certain things
that align with the interests of certain
nation states. And I don't dispute that.
Uh, my rise in the internet has been um
meteoric. It's surprised me. Um, but I'm
committed to education. I'm committed to
free debate. I'm committed to free
discussion. I am perfectly happy to
engage with people on both the left and
the right and I think like the path
forward is open and free debate.
>> Yeah, I completely agree. Gordon Chang,
what is your view of Professor Jang? Are
you happy to call him a professor and do
you think he's China's useful idiot?
>> You know, everything that that Professor
Jang just said, I I can certainly agree
with him. Um, so, um, I I understand
that that that title is something that
people have given him and that's that's
fine with me. You know, he has views.
Some of them align with what the
Communist Party of China believes. Some
of them do not, as we just heard. Um, so
um, he has his views and I I wouldn't
characterize him with that useless idiot
term. I think he just has views that
both do align and don't align with the
powers in China.
>> Yeah. which from from where I sit is a
actually a pretty good place to be. I
have the same about my own uh country
and my own government. I agree with them
about some things. I disagree with them
about others. Uh that last time I
checked is actually a pretty good place
for most people to find themselves. Uh
but anyway, I'm quite happy to call you
professor. Professor Jang, I think
you're you are an internet sensation.
It's great having you on uncensored
regularly now and please come back soon.
Thank you both very much.
>> Thank you.
>> Thanks guys. Well, joining me now are
two members of the Iranian diaspora with
very different views about the war and
what happens next. Sam Agar Agari, he's
the Iranian-American actor and Sarab
Amari, who's the Iranianamean journalist
and US editor of Unheard. Well, welcome
to both of you. um you know both
Iranians both have uh very strong views
about this and I'm very aware having
spoken to a lot of Iranians myself in
the last six weeks that opinions they've
evolved they've fluctuated people have
changed their minds completely as it's
gone on because obviously
those who wanted regime change have seen
the supreme leader taken down and many
of his top people taken down but the
regime itself
still appears to be intact. So, has
there been regime change? Many think
that hasn't happened. You know, has
there been a popular uprising by the
people? Not so far. Have the Iranian
Iranian regime, have they found a way to
strangle the global economy through the
straight of Hormuse in a way that may
have even surprised them? Yes. So, there
are lots of complexities to this and I
wouldn't pretend otherwise. But Sam, let
me start with you. Welcome back to
Uncensored. What was your view at the
start of the war on day one and what is
your view now?
>> My view from the start of the war till
now is the same. I mean nobody wants
war. Nobody wants innocent people dying.
Nobody wants the American uh soldiers
being sent overboard. Uh you know that
that uh caused any sort of casualty to
the innocent people between uh these two
governments. And that's that's been the
same. I mean, we never want war to
start, but we figured that this is going
to be the only way that this regime is
going to get weakened. And it has
already become weakened and it it it
sort of looks like there's a lot of
chaos that's happening within the
leaders that are left. So, my views are
are standing the same. But again, uh we
haven't really seen anything coming out
of Iran because the internet shutdown
and the total black blackout that they
had. So, it's it's very hard to see
what's really happening within the
people inside of Iran, but uh nobody
wants really to be bombed and nobody
wants to be under that much pressure,
especially when they were already under
economic pressure to begin with. And so,
we just figure to wait and see what
really happens within the next few weeks
in Iran to really figure out what's uh
what's going to be the future.
>> Okay. Uh Sarah, welcome to Uncensored.
Um what was your view on day one and
what is your view now?
>> My view on day one was driven mainly by
my status as an American, not someone
who happens to be born in Iran, which is
this was a war that the president more
or less explicitly said he wouldn't do
during his campaign, that it was
unpopular and that it would not serve US
national security interests. And my view
today remains the same. It's uh
surveying the field. It's uh completely
unclear whether this war has achieved
anything. The regime has hardened. There
is lots of signs of the rally around the
flag which I and many others like me
predicted. Um ideologically a lot of the
people who would have made a deal
potentially with the west are dead. As
the president himself said early on at
some point in an interview in the war,
the people who are left are younger
Islamic Revolutionary Guards Corps
members who are more radical and who are
in a way chafing under the restraint
imposed on them by the previous Supreme
Leader and now they feel unrestrained.
It's come down to whether or not the
straight of Hormuz stays open or closed.
In other words, it's come down to
restoring a status quo anti that
wouldn't have been disrupted but for the
war. And I'll say this, look, the reason
I'm speaking to you from New York rather
than Tan is because my family and I are
no fans of the Iranian regime. That's
there's no question about that.
>> It's a theocracy. It's been repressive.
Um, however, you have to think about
whether or not the experiences of the
post 911 years when the US tried these
kinds of wars in the Middle East have
served the US well, and they didn't.
They created um vast swats of stateless
and chaotic territory in places like
Libya that's still feeding migrants into
Europe. Uh Syria went through a brutal
civil war and then ended up uh under the
leadership of essentially an al-Qaeda
warlord. Afghanistan after 20 years of
blood and treasure expended is back in
the hands of the Taliban. And Iraq is
this mess that's kind of an Iranian
satropy. So with all that in mind, you
have to wonder what what's going to be
achieved. Now, there is a way to do
regime change in Iran, but it's not this
kind of warfare. You'd have to deploy
estimates range from half a million to a
million troops. And no one in the United
States has an appetite for that. So, you
know, I think if I'm and as in the
Iranian leadership, I'm actually feeling
pretty good right now having revealed my
ability to squeeze the global economy
and essentially I I now realize as an
Iranian leader, if I'm sitting at Thran,
I have a nuclear weapon
>> called the straight of Hormuz. Yeah. Um
it's been an enormous waste and um
potentially a a costly strategic blow to
the United States and that pains me as
an American.
>> Yeah. I I this is how I feel about it,
you know. Um Sam, bringing you back in
and one of my big problems with
President Trump in all this is the
constant mixed messaging and changing of
messaging. You know, at the launch of
what he called epic fury on February
28th, an address to the world, he said,
"Finally, to the great proud people of
Iran, I say tonight, the hour of your
freedom is at hand. When we are
finished, take over your government. It
will be yours to take." And we know from
the New York Times reporting several
days ago that Benjamin Netanyahu in the
White House situation room in the
buildup to this war, one of his
persuasive arguments to Trump was that
if you decapitate the leadership, then
there will be an uprising. And he even
went further Netanyahu and said that
there'll be no attention paid to the
straight of Hormoose because all the
attention will be on the IRGC
dismantling and the people taking over
and so on. Well, none of the rest of
that has happened. We've seen the
Ayatollah taken out, but replaced by his
son. We don't know the condition of the
son, but he's apparently still alive and
is the new supreme leader. There there
are 250,000 members of the IRGC. Many of
them are still there. uh underneath them
there's nearly half a million
paramilitaries heavily armed loyal to
the regime and below that there's the
standing army of nearly a million
people. So there's an enormous armed
force there and as Sarab said if you're
actually going to try and get rid of the
regime you got to have enough troops on
the ground to take on a force like that
and there's no appetite whatsoever for
anyone to do that. So that isn't going
to happen. So, you know, my problem has
been that
after Trump posted that, he then posts
only last week, "A whole civilization
will die tonight, never to be brought
back again. I don't want that to happen,
but it probably will." Which is the most
explicit uh sort of uh espousing of of
potential genocide I've ever heard an
American president come out with. Uh
he's basically saying, "We're going to
kill every Iranian." How that sits with
this is your hour of freedom at hand to
the Iranian people is completely
baffling to me. So, you know, as an
Iranian,
are you not finding that as problematic
as everybody else? I mean, do you not
think that that's a an extraordinary
double messaging coming out of the White
House?
as a American, I feel that that that's
not very presidential to speak uh when
it comes to uh tweeting or or whatever
social media that you use, especially if
this war or this operation ever started
because of humanity. You remember uh the
whole point was that Iranian people were
in need of help and that was the whole
campaign behind it. So that that's it's
something that absolutely as an American
I don't agree with as a person I don't
agree with and as a Iranianborn I don't
agree with but I think what the
president uh was trying to do here is
negotiate with the Iranians the way that
they speak he was speaking their
language and he sort of uh was doing
that. So but that that's something that
you don't usually do when it comes to
political aspect for the other people to
see. I mean, I see private messages
between uh them and the president of the
United States, that's one thing, but you
know, putting it out on the social media
and to sort of um play that role, it
doesn't really play uh for American
people, for the Iranian people. So, it's
absolutely not the way to speak. But
again, he has been really trying to talk
to these lunatics like like a lunatic.
>> Yeah. You see, I I just don't think that
is the correct way to do it. You know,
it's like, yeah, you can behave exactly
like your enemy, but if your argument is
that this enemy is a bunch of appalling
genocidal lunatics, um you should rise
above them. You should maintain a in
public at least a high moral ground, I
think. And I think, you know, the
problem with saying a whole civilization
will die tonight is that when they
don't, you become the boy that cried
wolf. you become the emperor with no
clothes. Your whole standing uh of
issuing these sort of apocalyptic
threats and then not carrying anything
out is that if you're the Iranian
regime, you're like, "Well, he blinked."
You know what, however Trump tries to
spin it, he blinked. And once you blink
and you're the president of the United
States, you know, I think as Sarab said,
then you're inviting the regime to feel
that, well, we had an existential threat
to our existence and it's not happened.
So in effect we have won. It's just a
question of the terms now.
>> Yeah. I mean I I think the I would harp
on the actually the strategic mistake.
Set aside the moral dimension which of
course horrified lots of people not
least the holy father Pope uh Pope Leo.
I happen to be a Catholic. Uh yeah me
too.
But but setting setting that aside, it
it just you know you remember those
hours he said I will essentially I will
rain fire upon you and destroy your
civilization. Especially talk of
civilization is so sensitive for
Iranians because they justly take pride
in a in a in a very old civilization.
>> Yeah.
>> 2,500 years old. and then you know in a
matter of hours to say yes I've I've
accepted the Iranian framework uh for as
a 10-point uh sort of opening for
negotiations which included Iranians
charging a toll uh for passage through
the straight of Hormuz. I mean that that
looks that looks ridiculous. And again,
American prestige is some of it rests on
this possibility that the United States
is this power that has several thousand
strategic weapons and could end truly
end a nation if it wanted to. But it's,
you know, the it was never said
explicitly and to have said it
explicitly and then to go back to a
position of well maybe the Iranian
10-point plan is a good basis for
negotiations is farcical. That's bad for
American power. And again, that's what
pains me more so even maybe than the
moral dimensions of the bluster.
>> Yeah. I mean, Sam, none of the 10 point
15 point plans, none of them actually
articulate regime change as something to
be negotiated even. So, it seems like
that's not even on the table at the
moment. Um, but again, I come back to
the the goalpost have changed so often
here. If I was Iranian, especially if I
was living in Iran, I'd be like, I just
don't understand what's what is
happening here, are we going to get to a
situation where because of the Strait of
Hormos being closed and the way that
it's been so effectively by the regime,
because of the way they've tactically
attacked their Gulf state neighbors in a
very damaging way to the business model
going forward for all of those Gulf
States? And I've been to them a lot in
the last couple of years. And if you're
in Saudi Arabia or Qatar or UAE, you
know, your business model you're selling
to the world that's been very successful
to date has been come here, it's safe,
it's sunny, it's going to be
entertainment to great for tourism,
great for sport and so on. And that
right now that's all on hold, which is
devastating to them. Um, so there's been
a double-pronged economic war being
waged by the regime, whilst the
Americans and the Israelis have been
waging a predominantly military war,
saying, "We've got overwhelming power.
We're going to destroy you." But, you
know, this asymmetric double war, I
don't think has worked for America in
particular. I don't think the Israelis
care, but I think Trump does, and he's
seeing the political damage now in the
polling. uh this was already a war most
Americans didn't approve of and that has
increased that disapproval. So I just my
gut feeling is Donald Trump got into
this because he believed that when
Netanyahu said all these things will
happen he believed it and the reality is
most of it hasn't happened. So in that
eventuality how long do you want to see
and I'm sorry to I don't mean to call
you an Iranian. I accept you're How
would you categorize yourself an Iranian
American? Is that how do how do you want
to be called?
>> Are you talking to me, Peters?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Born in Iran, made in America.
>> So, how do you what do you prefer? What
do you prefer to be? An Iranian American
or
>> I don't want to put words in your mouth.
>> I mean, I mean, sure. You know, America
gave me everything. So, I would consider
myself American Iranian.
>> Got it. But that that's you know Iran is
something that Iran here's the problem
with with Iran. We cannot sit here and
blame anybody else besides the
government of Iran. Those are the main
that's that is the main devil in the
Middle East. I mean, take a look at the
Middle East. Like you said, every single
country that's out in the Middle East,
even Turkey that's being ran by a
dictator is also, you know, weighing in
in the political field rather than, you
know, sitting alone and then saying we
don't want any foreign uh, you know,
foreign any companies, anything that
that that has to do to come to this
country and sort of they are the ones to
blame to hold this civilization back and
hold this country uh away from the
planet. I mean, Iran is being sort of
hostage from the planet and for that
country to be free, it's going to only
benefit not only the Middle East, but
but also the entire world. And we're
sort of missing that. So, it's sort of
hard to sit here and expl you know, try
to blame the United States.
>> No, no, just to be clear, I don't I
agree with you. Look, I I've got
absolutely no truck for the Iranian
regime whatsoever. And I shed no tears
when the Ayatollah was killed. You know,
let's let's be clear that they've waged
a campaign of terrorism against their
own people in Iran and they've been the
octopus with the tentacles of terrorism
throughout the Middle East and
predominantly aimed at Israel obviously
through the Houthis Ebola and Hamas and
so on. So, you know, just I think we're
all agreed on that. The question becomes
what do you do about it? And I'm just
sitting here looking at this war six
weeks in and thinking well the enriched
uranium remains buried away. They've no
idea where it is. Uh the regime in the
negotiation, the 21 hours they had the
other day made it clear they were not
going to surrender it and nor were they
going to agree to any extended
um ban on them developing a nuclear
weapon. Um you know, their argument
being, well, Israel's got a load of
them. Why shouldn't we have one? Uh I'd
imagine, which is actually not a bad
argument. Um the Israelis never like to
even admit if they have a nuclear
weapon, which I find baffling that the
world just accepts that. Um but but
putting that to one side, I just see a
situation here where this either drags
on interminably as we saw with Iraq and
all the problems that came out of that
or Trump just has to cut and run at some
stage and I guess if if the second thing
happens, how would you feel about that?
when it comes to, you know, the the
whole the whole brains and the whole
mentality behind this whole thing ever
started was was humanity for me and for
the Iranian people and uh you know this
situation the Iranian people are sort of
in between two blades of a scissor their
own government and you know being bombed
by another country that's supposedly be
being able to free them as as far as
other agendas you know in mind. So
either or you know my mentality behind
this is a loser and the Iranian people
are going to lose at the very extreme.
But it's gotten so bad that anything the
whole mentality was anything but this
anything but our government and then we
rather get bombed. That that mentality
is still there. You just don't see it
because of the blackout. But uh there
are times where people did ask for
something but they don't realize how
long it takes. you know this regime
change usually takes a lot longer than
you know 40 days of war. I mean even
average war is what 3 years or so. So we
are not taking into consideration the
timing that it takes you know if
the amount of years that it takes.
>> Yeah. But but Sam here's the problem
with that. I think the the reason is
that the Americans and probably Israelis
massively underestimated the ability of
the regime in Iran to strangle the
straight of Hormoose in the way they
have. And I think that that has proved
to be devastating even in a short 40-day
period. It's already been the biggest
seismic shock to the global energy
market ever in recorded history. So I
think that has been the thing that was
in my view grotesqually underestimated
and inexplicably underestimated because
it's it's not difficult to predict they
could do that. Um but I think the fact
the regime now knows it has that power
that gives them as as Sarab was saying
it it they don't really need a nuclear
weapon if they can just shut down that
straight when they see fit and cause
economic mayhem. And for Trump in
particular, it causes enormous political
damage in the run-up to midterm
elections.
>> Well, look, I mean, I I I think here is
the the real miscalculation. One source
of the miscalculation, and I've been
saying this uh for for years, you know,
I started out as a I started out the
Wall Street Journal editorial page, you
know, the comment pages of the journal,
which are famously very hawkish. And so
not maybe a decade ago, I was still
where basically Sam is, right? I was
like, well, we can, you know, we can use
American power to to liberalize the
world and so on. But then I had to look
at the outcome of those wars, as I said,
and and think that, you know, for the
most part, this kind of moralistic
foreign policy doesn't really work. Um,
but it was fed in the Iran case by
essentially too many in Washington and
probably in Jerusalem listening to only
like people like Sam and me and not
realizing and I I started warning about
this that look yes 10 20% of the
population urban educated is 100%
opposed to the regime and probably did
welcome the the bombing campaign early
on although as it wore on you started to
see, you know, the women who didn't wear
the hijab and the state TV would put
them on TV deliberately. Women without
hijab with like manicured French
manicured nails being like, "We're
standing with our supreme leader." Um,
some of that is propagandistic, but some
of it is real sentiment. But beyond that
10 20%, there is like a core of the of
the Iranian people who support the
regime. It's uncomfortable for us to
acknowledge, but they have bled for the
revolution. They gave thousands, tens of
hundreds of thousands of lives in the
Iran Iraq war. U they get both material
benefits and sort of spiritual and
ideological sustenance from the regime.
And they're true believers and they're
the sector of society that has a kind of
incumbency. They're the ones who are
armed. And then there is the poor
middle, the mushy middle, the 40 50%
that can go now this way or now that
way. Now, after all these year, after
all these events, I I would bet that
that mushy middle has actually been
dragged to the pole that was pro- regime
that was supportive of the regime
because no one likes to be bombed. No
one likes to see like the attacks like
the like the one on the Minab school in
Minab that killed hundred some school
girls. So, you know, I think listening
too much to this sector of of of the
diaspora which has a kind of rosy
picture. Many of them like myself,
that's why I try to be modest about my
foreign policy predictions. I haven't
been to Iran in 25 26 years. I don't
know the sorts of evolution that has
taken place. So, um, and I feel sort of
bad for the followers of Resa Pali. I
think, you know, monarchy is an ancient
tradition in Iran at 2500 years. And
there was a way I think that he could
have won something like his crown. And
that was to say something like this. I
deplore what's happening to my people.
Even if some of it is the fault of the
Iranian regime or much of it, I still
will do all that's in my power to stop
the West from from inflicting further
pain on Iran, standing up to, you know,
these kind of civil anti-Ivilizational
rhetoric and then he would have become a
kind of nationalist figure. but to have
said basically kind of become an
apologist for the operation and barely
raised the peep if any when the kind of
horrors of the war war unfolded.
I think he's now attained a status not
unlike that of the mujahedin the mek
which was the opposition group which
sided with Saddam Hussein. You know the
Iranians think you're with an enemy
against the homeland you are ostracized.
So now you have this enormous group of
people in the diaspora who's going to be
disillusioned. Their sha is never going
to go back. They're never going to have
a Palavi restoration.
Um it's, you know, you're going to have
an IRGC as stand a militarized North
Korea style regime which is wounded in
some ways but all the more vicious for
that.
>> Yeah. I mean uh let's bring Sam back in.
I mean, following the ceasefire, Resa
Palavi addressed supporters who were
disheartened by the pause in US strikes,
urging them to see the truth as proof of
regime weakness rather than defeat. And
he directly appealed to the Iranian
armed forces to fulfill their patriotic
oath by abandoning the regime and
protecting the people from foreign
mercenaries like Hezbollah and the PMF.
But obviously, there's not much sign of
any of that happening. And at the same
time, we have a former UK House of
Commons speaker John Burko addressing an
international conference in Paris uh
yesterday where he said this.
Mr. Palavi cannot be accused of too much
arduous work over the decades.
He was born into enormous wealth and
privilege. He scuttled off to the United
States four and a half decades AGO. I'M
NOT AWARE OF anything useful he's done
since, but apparently
he goes to bed at night. My source tells
me, eagerly entertaining the hope that
the moment is nigh,
the prince over the water
who will come to the rescue and achieve
a position of leadership.
Well,
I stopped believing in fairy tales
before I became a teenager. This guy is
now in his mid60s. I have to say to him
just as our little secret between Mr.
Palavi and me, mate,
you are deluded.
Sam, what do you what do you make of
that? What do you do?
>> You know, taking a look at a video of
somebody else uh speaking on behalf of a
lot of the Iranian people behav
dynasty going back and sort of siding
with the regime. Uh but I think it's
sort of listening to that is is
ridiculous. I did like his tie. Uh I
enjoyed uh the way his passion but but I
think but I think sort of speaking on
behalf of other people uh uh you know it
sort of gets ridiculous at times and
some sometimes we forget that the whole
reason why the diaspora of the Iranian
people that that rose up and spoke on
everything that was happening in Iran
before this war and even now was to be
the voice of the people of Iran and the
misinformation and and sort of you
saying what you wanted was sort of not
very helpful and it was just to echo the
voices of Iran and his you know he was
the main opposition and he was being
called out by not only the people inside
of Iran before this blackout but also
the diaspora as well and it's hard to
say that you know it's it's if you if
you take a look back at history and
let's say you know you can say you can
example countries like North Korea but
what about South Korea
What about Germany? What about uh you
know Hungary? What about some of the
Scandinavian countries? And what about
the countries that when it came to um
America helping out and America getting
into war? Again, wars never uh resolves
anything. But in history, it has freed
countries and it has made countries
great. And you know, if you take a look
at the Iranian regime, uh the regime is
stacked with layers and the way this
regime was designed. That's the main
issue, not the opposition group, not the
countries. Uh you know if you if you
take a look at Israel, sure Israel has
done some uh you know their own uh stuff
in Palestine and in Iran, but the Iran
the people of Iran are the ones that are
being shut down and shut out by the
internet. So we are that's that is the
main issue. The biggest issue is we are
not really understanding the percentage
of people. I don't think it's 20 to 30%
of the people. I think it's a lot more
than that. And it's not that we are
getting bombed. This whole thing started
of how weird it was as an Iranian to say
I'm glad another country is coming in
because how badly their own government
was handling and managing the
government. This wasn't about, you know,
wearing your hijab or covering. This was
about just economic management. I mean,
you got a you got a country that's
supposed to be one of the wealthiest
countries in the world and they they
don't have internet. They don't have
internet.
>> Is it better though? Is it better
though, Sam, on that point, is it better
to have an organic uh overthrowing of a
leader as we saw in Syria recently with
Assad, for example, where it's driven by
people from within Syria. Is that the
the best way to affect regime change? In
other words, you know, I'd have it was
interesting what what Sarab said earlier
because I think it was Sarah where you
touched on the fact that some people in
Iran may well have, you know, rallied
behind the regime against the bombing,
not because they like the regime, but
because they hate the bombing more. And
I I talked uh last week on the show
about a a a Kosovo who runs a cafe near
me who said it reminded him he had had
some Iranian customers come in who said
they had done that exact thing. You
know, they were very anti- the regime,
but they were more pro their country
than they were the country being bombed
by outside forces. And he said it
reminded him of what happened in Kosovo
when NATO attacked Malazovich. uh is
that quite a few Kosovans did in in the
end put their country ahead of their
hatred of Melovich and you know that
could explain why you're not seeing any
uprisings at the moment along with the
obvious issue of there's bombing
everywhere and so on and the memory of
what happened in January but but what do
you think to that argument? I think the
Iranian people don't have, like I said,
they're they're cut in between two
blades uh on the sharp end of of the
sword and and they're sort of they don't
have anything but to sit and back and
and and take uh the damage that's
happening. And the problem with the
Iranian government is they've they've
used that tactics for years. I mean,
they've used propaganda. That was their
most dangerous uh weapon that they used.
But their second was brainwashing. And
now that's gotten to an end. I mean,
it's been 50 years of that. People have
social media, people have internet,
people see how even Saudi Arabia and
Dubai has become such successful
countries and and and they use and
they're being managed by by people that
are using their brain. So I think
they've sort of have lost that uh you
know trust within their own government
for years, but they've been abandoned. I
mean, these people are I I extremely
feel bad for every single person that's
inside of Iran because they don't have
their own government. They're totally on
their own. They don't have anything.
They don't have bank systems right now
working. They don't know what the future
is. They don't have basic internet. But
it's the mentality of their own
government. Uh they rather their own
government being bombed. But yes, be
careful what you wish for. M I mean you
never if you never you know been bombed
before or never seen that of course
you're going to be frightened you know
of course it's going to be a moment
where you're going to realize this is so
bad
>> we're getting hit by every single angle
of life.
>> Yeah. Um, Sarah, let me bring you back
in because on this issue of propaganda
that there's a a meme that uh we have
here of of what they're talking about,
which is the way the Iranian regime is
kind of using digital propaganda to get
to people in the West in particular.
Let's take a look.
>> You ain't nothing but a fraud. Call him
what he is. Liar.
>> Yeah. Hey. Hey. Hey. Loser. Come closer.
I'm the exposer. Fake billionaire. Your
whole empire oppos. You step down.
Another liar takes the crown. The whole
system is a circus. You're just a clown.
You drop fake news. Sitting high in your
tower. Morally bankrupt. Just drunk on
the power.
>> You know what's interesting about that
to me? I I think Sarab is it's wellm
made. It's very slick. It was
commissioned by the Iranian regime. Um
and not all the memes coming out of Iran
are using humor. This one was posted a
few days ago by the Iran embassy in
Tajakhstan
mocking President Trump as Jesus after
Trump obviously reposted that meme.
Let's take a look at this.
>> Your reckoning HAS COME.
>> WHAT IS THIS?
SO, you know, it's sort of effective use
of modern social media tools to get
their point over and I think it's
undeniably been quite effective. What do
you think, Sarah?
>> Yeah, look, I mean,
notice how much more nimble they are in
terms of their messaging. What they're
trying to do is is drive a wedge between
Western, especially American domestic
audiences that didn't vote for this war.
A lot of the
people who rallied to Trump in 2024,
young men, about a fifth of
African-American men, a half of Hispanic
men, they thought they were getting uh
the peace ticket as the RNC called
itself. And it was one of the most
appealing things about President Trump
beginning in 2016 is he ran as a critic
of the neoconservative hawkish
establishment in both parties that had
launched a bunch of point what he called
disastrous wars in that famous uh
February 2016 debate with Senator uh
with Jeb Bush, Senator Cruz and the
others. You know, at the time it was I
was on the right and I'm still in some
ways of of the right, but it was so
taboo to point out that Iraq had been a
disaster and Trump just came out and
said it and he flipped the script
totally on all of this stuff. And that's
what made him attractive. And so then
for him to launch wars gives the
Iranians an opportunity in their
propaganda to separate his supporters
from the from the administration. And
again, it's nimble in the sense that the
target is Trump or what the Iranians
call the so-called Epstein class, things
like that. They don't they don't attack
a whole American civilization. By
contrast, you have, you know, figures
like Secretary of War Pete Hexath and
and uh uh President Trump using this
very crude rhetoric targeting a whole
civilization or talking about driving
Iran back to the stone age, having as
you pointed out, Pierce, launched the
war on the promise of help is on the
way. And how did you feel s about the
the attack on the pope, Pope Leo, the
first American pope obviously, which
came in the same sort of 48 hour cycle
as Trump reposting a meme of himself as
Jesus, even though he now ridiculously
pretends he he thought he was a doctor.
But this sort of double-pronged attack
both on sort of mocking Christianity in
a way that offended even his most
committed MAGA supporters, many of whom
of course are very committed to uh to
Christianity, probably more intently
than they are to Trump himself. So
completely crazy thing to do I thought
politically, never mind anything else.
But the attack in particular on the Pope
who his only argument has been that he
just wants the war war to stop. He
thinks war is bad because it kills a lot
of people. What did you feel about that
as a Catholic?
>> Well, look, I was I was I was offended.
You know, as as Catholics, we we look to
the Pope as as a as a spiritual father.
He's he's the vicor of Christ. He's the
successor of St. Peter. In the book of
Acts, there's a there's a verse that
says that when Peter came around, uh the
the people would bring their the the ill
and disabled and his they would lay
their disabled and sick people in in the
path of Peter so that his shadow might
fall on them and heal them. So, that's
the kind of level of authority you're
talking about. And you know, there was
something bizarre about that message of
saying Pio is weak on crime as though
he's talking about like a local mayor.
Um, and it suggest it really did go into
dementia territory because I think Trump
has like a grabag of insults in his
head. It's like Barack Hussein Obama
weak on crime. Leo, we can't and you
know, so and look, the fact is that Pope
Leo is also not only speaking from this
deep tradition of of the just war theory
that the Catholic Church has developed
where war is seen as an evil and it
doesn't say that you can never wage war,
but it has to be under very strict
conditions. And he's not only speaking
from within that tradition, but he's
also just addressing where popular
sentiment is in the United States. Pope
Leo has a plus 34 popularity rating in
the United States. Trump has a -12,
depending on which poll you look, some
are much worse, has a -12 spread, like a
popularity or favorability spread. So,
um, it's bizarre to take take, even
politically speaking, again, set aside
the morality of it, it's weird to take a
pick a fight like that with the pope and
to pick a fight and treat him like any
other politician rather than a global
spiritual leader.
>> Yeah, I agree. Um just just finally uh
Sam I was struck by the fact the new
Iranian president Massud Pazikian backed
the pope posting his holiness Pope Leo I
condemn the insult to your excellency on
behalf of the great nation of Iran and
declare that the desecration of Jesus
the prophet of peace and brotherhood is
not acceptable to any free person. I
wish you glory by Allah. Uh pretty
extraordinary thing to see coming out of
the mouth of the president of Iran. Were
you surprised to see that? And what do
you make of this whole row that Trump's
having with the Pope?
>> Uh, absolutely not. I'm not surprised
for the Iranian government to use any
opportunity that they have to target and
to try to be the good guys here. I mean,
that's what they've done the best.
That's what they've done to get power
and that's what they continue doing and
the only people that are seeing through
the lies are the people of Iran that are
asking for some sort of a change for a
better future. So, you know, watching
growing up in a country like that and
being brainwashed and and sort of being
told something that's not and sort of
having the whole politician uh very very
bad politician that the Iranians are
sort of give me the understanding that
politics was no no longer the interest
to me. And you know when I when I look
at these things online I I figure
sometimes when things are being said
they could be the most anti-American
thing even though you are trying to be
very American. So that's where my issues
with politics come in. And you know,
just being an Iranian uh born and seeing
what that country turned into and the
management part of it uh made me just
hate politics and then fall in love with
humanity and and really try to uh pick
up from the person and not just what
they're saying. So, you know, I cannot
get good energy and good vibes if we
want to put it into simple terms from
the people from the government of Iran.
Absolutely not. So, I don't care what
they do. Even if they uh tweet my
picture and say, "We love Sam." I I
don't I don't care. I don't I don't
>> And very very quickly, Sam, because we
we've run out of time, but um let's go
forward six months. Putting aside what
you hope would happen, based on where we
are today, what do you think will happen
eventually within the six months range?
I think it's a short amount of time to
really determine what's going to happen,
but for the people of Iran, what I'm
hearing from the inside is that this is
only going to get better. And I hope
this war stops and I and I hope there is
a deal into a new future for the people
of Iran, new management. And I think
it's more realistic to look down three
to five years to see real change coming
from that government. And I think that
that regime is going to get weakened and
they are not going to be as as uh iron
fist when it comes to their ideology as
the previous leaders were. And I think
you know within the years they're only
going to be weakened and we're going to
have an opportunity to create a leader
for that country by the people from the
people.
>> Okay. Sabb quickly what do you think?
What?
>> Look, I I I I I think that there's going
to be a non-aggreement agreement where
President Trump walks away and various
countries strike bilateral deals to give
some sort of toll to the Iranians which
will count as their reparation, as their
consolation prize for this. Um there's
going to be kind of uneasiness, an
uneasy relationship with Israel ongoing.
uh you know so Iran is will almost
certainly run to China and Russia and
try to beef up its defenses for the next
round. But I don't I don't see uh you
know regime change of the of any kind. I
think that this crew will continue to be
in charge. You can kill this guy but
there's layers and layers behind each
one leader. What you will see though, I
think Sam's right in one sense, which is
they're going to let up on some of the
sort of morality policing. Honestly, the
hijab thing had already the hijab rule
had already been severely weakened. It's
still on the books, but they weren't
really enforcing it after the 2022
uprising. So, you see right now, I mean,
I watch state TV daily just to get a
sense of what they're up to. And you see
women without hijab on state TV, like
they show them protesting on the
streets. So um you know some new bayat
we call it some new sort of uh pledge of
allegiance will form between the regime
and the society which will take into
account these uh changes that have taken
place. But in terms of Iran's strategic
presence in the region as and as a
regime, I think it's again I maintain
it's only been strengthened by this war.
And that's why I, you know, wish the
president had listened to people like
Pope Cleo who who would invade against
um this kind of willy-nilly war making.
>> Fascinating conversation. Thank you both
very much.
As I said at the top of the show, the
president last week addressed the
criticism that Iranian protesters never
stood a chance without weapons. Well,
speaking to Trey Yinster, Fox News, he
said the US did try to arm Iranians by
sending weapons to the Kurds who stole
them. Well, joining me to respond to
that is Baffled Talibani. He's the
president of the Patriotic Union of
Kurdistan. Welcome back to Uncensored.
>> Thank you, Mr. Morgan.
>> Did you steal them?
No, I didn't actually. But um you know,
Kurdistan is a tale of two cities. We're
kind of a country, but not a country. We
have a government that's not really a
government. Um I can guarantee you on
the Sulmania side, not a people stolen,
and I think you have enough friends in
the administration to confirm that. I
can't speak for the other side.
>> So, what was your view of what of what
President Trump said?
I mean, if that's the case, and I'm sure
that those words didn't come out of of
nowhere, I think it's absolutely
shameful. I mean, if it's it's one thing
to be to think that that tactic of using
the Kurds as the bullw walk of the
assaults was a bad idea, but it's a
completely other thing to steal from
your allies.
>> Will there be any repercussions?
>> I wouldn't want to steal from Mr. Trump,
would you?
>> Not particularly. No, I wouldn't. No, I
I I presume they will be.
>> In terms of the wider war, what is your
perspective on where we've reached here
six weeks on?
>> Looking at it a bit differently, Mr.
Morgan. Um I think that uh patience is
required is the number one thing. Uh but
I think that instead of a small win,
there could be the opportunity for a
larger win if the Americans are thinking
that way.
>> And Mr. Trump's book indicates some of
that. I think that if they concentrated
on perhaps not just this immediate
conflict, but all the things in the
Middle East that contribute to this
conflict and exasperate this conflict,
perhaps there's an opportunity for a
greater understanding and a bigger deal.
A deal regarding the Palestinians, a
deal regarding um what's happening now
in Lebanon, for example. I think if the
American administration went for a
bigger deal, absolutely it would take
more time, but the victory would be
colossal and it would be a change in the
Middle East. It would be a real win. And
I think the numbers in the um upcoming
elections in the United States would be
very favorable to the Republicans.
>> It would take the patience for that.
Sorry. Sorry, sir. Please.
>> Well, no. I say I think it would take a
lot of patience. I'm not entirely sure
that Donald Trump has a lot of that
generally. Um, and it takes a lot of
commitment and money and so on. in in
terms of um this idea of regime change.
>> Yes,
>> there was a big piece in the New York
Times a few days ago suggesting that
Benjamin Netanyahu painted a picture to
Trump which Trump clearly bought into
that if you decapitated the leadership
of of Iran and kill the Ayatollah that
it would lead to regime change that the
IRGC would basically fragment and then
collapse and the people would rise up
and you would have a a change of regime.
Was that ever likely and is that even
possible do you think? Honestly, Mr.
Morgan, I don't believe so. I think that
the um the bombing campaigns have had
the adverse effect. Um you can speak to
Iranians. We do. Thousands of Kurds
contact us. They can even tell who's
bombing from the targets. Mr. Morgan,
this may be something you haven't heard
before. Every time a school is
destroyed, every time a university is
destroyed, every time a hospital is
destroyed, they know it's not the
Americans. I can't see how that's
helpful. Um and you you can't bomb
people into loving you. I just don't
believe it. Um and I think the tactic is
wrong and it's having the adverse
effect. We've seen people demonstrating
who have been interviewed. Madam, you
were here six months ago
um demonstrating against the regime and
they say we're not demonstrating for the
regime now. We're demonstrating for our
country, for our land, for our soil. And
that's understandable. I think your
Kosovo example was extremely astute.
Yeah, it was very it was passed to me uh
by Kosovan. That's why I I thought it
had great credibility and I do I do I
was trying to think what would happen
with the UK for example, right? If we
were bombed here, however unpopular the
government at the time, I think you
would see people rally behind the
country. I think it's it's an
instinctive human reaction.
>> It's it's exactly that. It's a human
reaction. I think one of the dangers is
listening to the diaspora and to refugee
communities. when we were in the UK, we
were so against Saddam, we would have
said anything. Um, and I think that
maybe the the Iranians in America are
wonderful, educated people. They may not
be the right people to listen to. I
think that the United States has great
intelligence. They have very good
friends that are very close to them and
I I think that that's who they should be
listening to. Um, you know, I'm
optimistic now that uh the Pakistanis
are sending a team to Tehran very soon
to continue the negotiations and I think
one day where everything didn't go well
shouldn't be the end of it. There was
progress made, Mr. Morgan, on many of
the smaller issues. I think a lot of
progress was made. I've heard this from
both sides. So I think given the
opportunity for things to continue and
this ceasefire deadline isn't written in
stone, it's very easy to extend things
and my hope is that people will see
sense and realize that this is one of
those conflicts that violence will not
resolve.
>> Baffl Talbani, thank you very much
indeed. You're always welcome on our
sensor, not least because I think you're
the only guest who regularly calls me
Mr. Morgan, uh, which I greatly
appreciate. So Mr. Talbani, thank you.
Thank you very much, Mr. Morgan.
>> Piers Morgan Uncensored is proudly
independent. The only boss around here
is me. If you enjoy our show, we ask for
only one simple thing. Hit subscribe on
YouTube and follow Piers Morgan
Uncensored on Spotify and Apple Podcast.
And in return, we will continue our
mission to inform, irritate, and
entertain. And we'll do it all for free.
Independent uncensored media has never
been more critical, and we couldn't do
it without you.